is Donald Trump a racist we will talk
about it plus the me2 movement goes
completely off the rails and Hawaii
apparently almost got nude or not really
but things went wrong we'll talk about
that as well i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
so today is a day that America
celebrates a great man's birthday mine
no I'm just joking it's Martin Luther
King Day it is also my birthday but of
course today is Martin Luther King Day
and I have some Martin Luther King Day
recommendations a little bit later in
the show
I also want to get to everything Trump
related the fact that Hawaii is not
under nuclear assault as well as this
crazy story that somebody put forward
about Aziz Ansari the comedian he's
really obnoxious as he's done sorry but
the implication that he's on sorry some
sort of incipient rapist and that we all
have to lump him in with the rest of the
me2 movement the mean to movement is
really going overboard at this point
something I have feared for a while I'll
talk about all of that first I want to
say thank you to our new sponsors over
at Legal Zoom so right now your thing
about starting a new business or you're
thinking about having to will or think
about having to is an estate plan well
LegalZoom is for you plus if you need
legal advice Legal Zoom is for you they
can help make this a memorable year
before all the distractions take hold
this is the year you finally get serious
about launching and running your
business and the legal part of your
business is a very expensive part of
your business unless you are going to my
friends at Legal Zoom Legal Zoom has
been helping people like you take care
of their dreams and responsibilities for
more than 16 years look I'm a lawyer I
know how much it costs for legal
services and Legal Zoom is far less
expensive and it's just as good they
have all the forms that you need they
have people who are there giving advice
to you when you get a subscription plan
they're not a law firm but they have the
resources to keep you on the right path
including advice from their network of
independent attorneys all at your
fingertips so whether you want to take
your business to the next level or take
control of your family's future with
that estate plan Legal Zoom plugs right
into your life so you can take care of
the things that matter most again as a
lawyer I've used Legal Zoom myself it's
that good get off to a strong start
legalzoom.com today Legal Zoom calm and
you get special savings when you enter
been in the promo box at checkout so use
that promo code Ben you will get some
special deals and discounts on their
services plus when you go to
legalzoom.com use promo code Ben that
lets them know that we sent you as well
again Legal Zoom where life meets legal
and again your business is gonna cost a
lot of money if you go to lawyers who
charge 500 bucks an hour that is not the
deal the Legal Zoom and it's just as
good in most cases so go to
legalzoom.com today and again use that
special promo code Ben at checkout and
get a discount as well alrighty so over
the weekend the media have decided that
pres
Trump's a racist now that's no different
from any other weekend every weekend the
media decide the President Trump is
racist now some weekends they have more
material than others to call President
Trump a racist now let me start with
this I want to start by talking about
what makes someone a racist what makes
someone racist so I think there are a
few different ways to look at this one
is a person whose entire worldview is
inherently racist so this would be like
the Richard Spencer a group of people
people who think that black people are
innately inferior more prone to
criminality have lower IQs but not that
that had not not in terms of it's not
racist to suggest that black folks on
average may have lower IQs because race
racial groups differentiate but that
that is a natural thing and that that
has behavioral consequences that cannot
be cured by culture right there that you
run this really dicey territory there
but the idea that that you believe that
black people are innately inferior the
morally inferior that they are they're
inferior by dint of their skin color and
their genetics right that is racist okay
that's what racism is Richard Spencer is
one type of racism then there are people
who say racist things right you say a
racist thing so when President Trump for
example said that he didn't condemn the
KKK and didn't know who they were that
was a racist thing in my view I talked
about it at the time and then people say
race' al Sharpton when when he says
things about Jews that are racist or
anti-semitic those are anti-semitic
things to say when people do racist
things when people discriminate against
black people in their businesses or
discriminate against black people in
their housing right these are racist
things but I think that what the media
are trying to do right now is use the
term racist and label people racists are
not actions not activities I'm always
hesitant to label anyone overtly racist
it said the person themselves is
completely racist unless we are
suggesting that their entire worldview
is dominated by racism now there are
racists obviously whose entire worldview
is not dominated by racism but when it
comes to public policy when it comes to
public figures we have to determine
what's the usefulness of saying whether
somebody is a racist or not now there
are three reasons why you would say
somebody is a racist and I'm gonna get
to why I'm talking about this and all
this all of this in a second there are
three reasons why you might suggest that
somebody is racist one it's just true
you're saying it because you apply it
across the spectrum when someone holds
racist views then you are going to call
it out al Sharpton is a ray
and you think Donald Trump is racist or
Al Sharpton is a racist and and and
Richard Spencer is a racist and Jared
Taylor is a racist right you're going to
try and call out racism wherever you see
it and you're going to label people
racist based on their worldview hey
that's reason number one reason number
two is because you're trying to use
racism as a baton to wield against
somebody so this is when people suggest
that everybody on the right is a racist
and that's why they can't be trusted
right there's just a political baton
that you're using to wield against
somebody because racism is the most
dangerous charge you can throw against
somebody in public life right that if
you shout somebody's racist you never
have to listen to them again that's the
idea here okay and then there's reason
number three once you label somebody a
racist overall once you say that Donald
Trump for example is a racist which is
what the media have been saying over the
weekend once you say Donald Trump is
racist then what you are doing what
you're doing is allowing yourself the
ability to avoid evaluating individual
instances of racism it allows you the
ability to avoid saying whether he just
did something racist or whether maybe
there is another reason so for example
if you think Donald Trump is a racist
now every time you talk about his
immigration policy you don't actually
have to evaluate whether the immigration
policy is bad or good whether it is
being driven by racial considerations or
whether it is just a immigration policy
that makes sense for a variety of other
reasons once you call somebody a racist
it allows you the ability to avoid
saying what you think is it good or bad
about a policy right it allows you to
paint with a broad brush so this brings
us to Trump's statements last week as we
talked about at length on Friday
president Trump is now accused by a
bunch of Democrats and at least one
Republican Lindsey Graham of saying that
people from bleep whole countries should
not come to the United States now there
are two ways to read that comment as I
talked about on Friday way one to read
it is the racist way you're from Haiti
therefore you don't belong here because
Haitians cannot assimilate and Haitians
are stupid and bad and dirty and have
AIDS right that's that that that's sort
of the racist way of reading what Trump
said and that links in with some
accusations the aids come it
particularly links into an accusation
made about Trump in the New York Times
back in June in which Trump supposedly
said that all Haitians have AIDS okay
that that was disputed by the White
House they deny that comments entirely
and you don't know what to believe
because it was it was anonymously
sourced okay that is way one of reading
it that Trump was saying I don't want
more black people here
more Haitians here I don't want more
people from Ghana here get them out
they're the wrong color they're the
wrong race they're the wrong ethnicity
therefore they should leave right that's
way one of reading this and people
reading Trump's comments in light of
what he said about Mexican judges for
example they will say obviously this is
an instance of racism because the
president is a racist okay then there's
way to of reading the comments which is
Trump was specifically talking about the
diversity video the diversity Visa
Lottery where we determine by country
who to let in and he was saying why do
we need more people from Ghana as
opposed to more people from Great
Britain why do we need more people from
Russia as opposed to more people from
Great Britain if you're going to make
differentiations among countries then we
have to have a hierarchy of countries
that we give priority to why would we
have less people from South Korea when
we could have more people from South
Korea and fewer people from Haiti right
that's way to of reading it and that one
is not really racist it's not really
even bigoted that way is is trying to
force people into thinking about which
countries are most likely to provide
citizens who are most likely to
assimilate to American values hey that's
the way to have reading it now how do
you read that comment is basically a
Rorschach test on what you think of
Trump but what's happened is that the
media have been so determined bound and
determined to hit Trump with the racist
charge and read his comments in light of
this background that he's racist that
this prevents them from actually having
to make an argument about the diversity
Visa Lottery or about policy I think
there's some ulterior motives going on
in any case so let's go through this
first let's point out a bunch of
Republicans denied the Trump Senate now
Republicans denying the Trump said it
I've been pretty weak on this stuff so
sonny perdue who is or who is a senator
or sorry David Perdue not sonny Perdue
David Perdue who is the senator from
Georgia he was in the room when Trump
apparently said this stuff and he denies
the Trump ever said this stuff what he
is really saying and what the
Republicans are saying is that Trump
didn't say that these people come from
bleep whole countries he said they come
from bleep house countries which makes
no difference whatsoever so that's the
peg you're gonna hang your hat on forget
about it
here is a David Perdue denying the Trump
ever said this stuff those comments have
been confirmed by multiple sources
you're saying it didn't happen multiple
sources there were six of us in the room
I haven't heard any of those six sources
other than Senator Durbin talk about
what was said
basically accurate well that's the
you'll have to deal with him but
basically as an operative word the
trouble here is that Senator Durbin came
and brought a proposal and let's put
this in perspective I want to but you're
saying you're saying flat-out
definitively the president did not say
those words I'm saying that this is a
gross misrepresentation it's not the
first time Senator Durbin has done it
and it is not productive to solve it one
day so there's denial happening from
Purdue Tom cotton also was asked about
this he also denied the Trump said this
and then he was grilled whether dick
Durbin the senator from Illinois was
lying about it here's what cotton had to
say what Senator Durbin senator Graham
proposed is to expand our country of
origin and quota based system the
president reacted strongly against that
as he should and I do as well because we
want to get away from a country of
origin system that treats people as
Nigerians or Norwegians and treats them
as individuals and doctors and
scientists and computer programmers and
so forth I understand your sentiment
you're quite clear on that but the
president sentiment you're saying in all
of these meetings there was never an
instance in which he did what you're
saying just and when he grouped John in
it in his in his tweets and his
interviews and his public statements
just Tuesday when we had the large
meeting the Cabinet Room he repeatedly
insists that we need to move to a skills
basis we're in the room where it happens
so you're saying in that room you didn't
hear any of this sort of lumping
everybody together is that what you're
saying I did not hear derogatory
comments about individuals or persons
okay so he's basically not denying the
account he's just he's accounting for it
the way that I accounted for right he's
trying to explain away what from said
using this explanation I don't find it
completely implausible now in a second
I'm going to explain what the New York
Times is saying about this right well
the New York Times are trying to do is
create this backdrop or Trump is racist
so we don't even have to evaluate
whether the statement itself was racist
we don't have to evaluate whether Trump
was saying something terrible we can
just call him a racist overall get to
that in just one second first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
wink so you know right now you are
you're sitting at home and you're
thinking yourself I could use a bottle
of wine because let's face it the
holidays are over we're getting back
into the work year and you want to relax
with a nice bottle of wine or you have
to go over to somebody's house tonight
and you want to bring a bottle of wine
but you don't know anything about wine I
mean you're more likely to go down to
the local liquor store just pick up a
bottle of Manischewitz and bring it
there and it tastes like cough syrup
instead what you ought to be
is going over to wink its winc wink
makes it easy to discover great wine
winks wine experts selected wines
matched to your taste personalized for
you shipped right to your door and
starting just $13 a bottle they'll send
you a personalized gift card and let
your recipient choose their wine as well
okay here's how it works you go over to
linked calm and then you check out their
palate profile quiz they asked a bunch
of simple questions they profile you and
then finally they ask they'll ask you
things like how do you take your coffee
how do you feel about blueberries and
then determining kind of what you like
to drink what you like to eat they send
wines curated to your taste and every
month there are new delicious wines like
the insane you're insanely popular
summer water rose a people around the
office are consistently drunk from rum
wink and that is why they the quality of
the shows declined so markedly in recent
weeks but if you check it out try wink
calm slash mint tea ry winc comm slash
man you get $20 off your first shipment
that's try winked calm t ry winc calm
slash been for twenty bucks off again
try blink comm slash been not only are
gonna get get a great bottle of wine
it's gonna be personalized at just to
you so try blink comm slash man again
shipping it's complimentary if you don't
like a bottle they'll send you they
replace it with a bottle you love no
questions asked which is pretty awesome
try winked comm so I spend twenty bucks
off your first shipment okay so check
that out alright so as I say yea there
there are a couple of different ways to
read Trump's comments and the goal of
the media here is to make it seem as
though there's only one way to read
Trump's comment the way in the most
racist light possible the most racist
like possible now listen as I say I
don't think it's implausible that Trump
said something racist here I don't write
me love I think had a had a solid take
on this the representative whose parents
are from Haiti she was speaking on State
of the Union with tapper on Siena and
and here's what she had to say
Republican from Utah what do you say to
the Haitian American who comes to you
and says congresswoman I think the
president's racist well here's what I
say my parents have always taught me not
to be a victim my parents have taught me
that no matter what somebody else feels
that's their problem not mine
that I'm not the one that's flawed when
somebody feels some way about me because
of the way I look or my gender or
whatever that is where the comments
racist do you think well yeah I think
they were yes I think that there were
unfortunate I don't know if they were
taken I I wasn't in the room I know the
comments were made I don't know which
context they were made I'm looking
forward to finding out what happened but
more importantly I'm looking forward to
it okay so the reason that she hesitates
before she says yes is because again
there are two plausible reads it's not
just because Republicans are trying to
avoid the implication that the President
of the United States is a racist it's
also because there are actually ways of
reading that statement that are not
racist but well the New York Times is
trying to do is now create a narrative
whereby Trump is racist so everything
that he says must now be seen in that
light now do I think that president
Trump's entire ideology is dominated by
a belief about the differences between
races I don't believe that I don't and I
don't see that in President Trump I
think the president Trump's has
dunderheaded things I think he's like a
1960s al Archie Bunker type who has a
route level of disdain for people for
groups but then it's individuals he
overcomes that that's that's my general
take on him maybe I'm wrong but that's
that's my psychological rate I don't
like doing psychological reads on people
typically because again it prevents you
from actually doing a read on particular
instances of what the people are saying
so here's what I went to I keep setting
the earth time so today the New York
Times has a long piece by David Leon
Hart who is one of the assistant op-eds
over at the New York Times called Donald
Trump's racism the definitive list
okay this follows hard on a piece from
Charles blow call just say at trumpet
sorry by Leonhardt called just say at
Trump is a racist in that piece
Leonhardt a couple days ago wrote is it
possible to defend some of his racially
charged statements by pointing out that
something other than race might explain
them sure is it possible that he doesn't
think of himself as a racist who views
white people as superior to non-white
people
yes but the definition of a racist the
textbook definition is Paul Ryan might
say is someone who treats some people
better than others because of their race
okay but because of their race is the
entire question is he treating people
differently because of their race or
because of some other factor and this is
the laziness of the New York Times and
laziness of the left by calling Trump a
racist the idea is that now they don't
actually have to evaluate any of these
instances on an individual level and
here is the here is the
so if you actually look at the list then
that is put together by leonhart
inanimate iron filbrick here's their
list of trumps definitive racism it
includes things that are obviously
racist or racially tinged right stating
that a judge of Mexican descent would be
unable to adjudicate his Trump
University fraud case because of his
ethnicity I talked about that at the
time I said it was racist Trump refusing
to condemn the KKK on live TV I talked
about that at the time I said I thought
it was racist Trump saying there were
good people marching in an anti-semitic
racist torchlight parade in
Charlottesville I thought that that was
a problem right I said this at the time
but here's the problem the list also
includes a bunch of stuff that is not
racist right includes a bunch of stuff
that it best is questionable right then
they're a bunch of statements that have
been repeated by third parties but not
by Trump himself and not in public right
there was a guy who accused Trump of
saying at one point that laziness was a
trait in blacks
there's that New York Times report a
couple of weeks ago saying the Trump had
said all Haitians have AIDS none of
these are confirmed so you can't take
those at the same value that you take as
public statements or the stuff that's
been reliably reported but here's the
biggest problem Leonhardt and the New
York Times then name a bunch of
instances they call racist where there's
no evidence at all that racism is the
motivating factor so you remember during
the campaign Trump at one point pointed
out a black guy in the audience and he
said there's my african-american over
there is that racism is that really
racism I don't think so I think it's
trumping an idiot does that sound like a
guy like is that a guy who's saying
blacks are inferior therefore there's my
african-american or does sound like I'm
so proud that some african-americans
support me and there's the black guy who
supports me in the crowd right so stupid
but it's obviously not racist in fact
it's the opposite it's from saying I'm
proud to have black support and they can
they cite as evidence of Trump's racism
Trump calling Elizabeth Warren
Pocahontas okay that's not racist
Elizabeth Warren was the one who
appropriated Native American Heritage in
order to get a job at Harvard Law School
apparently and from calling her
Pocahontas is a way of mocking her not
mocking Native Americans they say the
Trump support for Roy Moore was
obviously racist are you kidding
all right kidding Trump supported Roy
Moore because that was the only
candidate left in the race and because
Trump was suckered by Steve ban and into
supporting Roy Moore he said Trump
supported joe arpaio and that's because
Trump is a racist okay Trump pardoned
Joe Arpaio not cos Trump's a racist but
because Trump is hardcore on immigration
and Joe Arpaio was perceived as an
immigration Hawk maybe you make the
argument it's racist but that is dubious
at best
I'm not sure how you make that argument
exactly and then they name instances
where Trump was that those are the ones
that are even questionable here are the
ones where he's obviously not being
racist right Trump they say the Trump
complains about the growing threat of
radical Islamic terrorism abroad how in
the world is that racist first o Islam
is not a religion what the hell are they
talking about or Trump criticising crime
rates in inner-city communities the
whole point of him talking about that is
to reduce the crime rates in the
inner-city communities that is literally
the entire point of him talking about
that but they lumped that in with
Trump's a racist Trump calling Obama
lazy okay they're saying that's because
he's racist against Obama or is it
because Trump calls everybody lazy and
he's a jerk and is it also because Obama
used to go golfing a lot I mean it's
just silly then there are instances the
lie somewhere in between right
instances where it's not clear that this
is because of racism but it's convenient
for people to talk about it as though
it's because of racism so Trump's
birtherism for example is that racism or
is it just that Donald Trump is saying
that stuff because it was politically
useful for him to do so at the time I
mean he basically admitted that he
wasn't necessarily a birther he just
wanted to pander to the birthers is that
racism is a quasi racism not supremely
clear my point is this each one of these
instances to solid should be adjudicated
on its own merits but what the media are
trying to do by labeling Trump a racist
is avoid having to adjudicate any of
these on their own merits now everything
Trump says is going to be painted with
the brush of racism so as I say to go
back to my framework there are only
three reasons why in politics you label
somebody racist one is you actually are
thoroughgoing about whom you labeled a
racist so for example I said that the
Obama administration was a jew-hating
administration because of their
treatment of Israel and I had said that
people on the right like Pat Buchanan
are jus hating because of their
treatment of Israel
I'm very consistent about how I address
these particular topics the media are
not they will never call al Sharpton a
racist in fact they'll call they will
quote al Sharpton calling Trump a racist
right so the media are not consistent
about this if you're not going to use
the term racism in a in a in actual
consistent way then it looks more like
you're using it as weapon which is the
second rationale for using the term
racism is use it as a weapon to shut
people down to suggest that like I've
been called a racist a thousand times
I'm obviously not a racist and anyone
calls me so is a jackass the idea that
I'm a racist is absurd
I've repeatedly and forcefully
spoken out about racism at every
opportunity that I can find but people
call you racist because they're
attempting to shut down the debate right
it's the it's the best epithet you can
use in American politics and the media
are doing that so they can drive Trump
into the ground finally there's the
third rationale and that is the
rationale I'm talking about it
alleviates the media from the
consequences of having to judge whether
anything Trump does is specifically
racist or not and there's something else
too
if they don't have to do that if they
can label Trump a racist and then
something comes up that's at best dicey
right the the bleep hole comments being
a case where it's it's dicey right I
would suggest that he never should have
said them because Trump's stupidity and
vagueness leads to problems for him on
issues like this but they're too
plausible reason this is situation
instead of offering the two plausible
reads of the situation you see the media
immediately jumping to everything he
says is racist the media is doing
something else here too which is if you
don't label it racist the media then
labels you racist so the media will take
an incident that is dicey and then
they'll say obviously it's racist cuz
Trump is a racist and then if you say
well but the situation's dicey they say
no no no you're a racist because you
won't label it racist so it's a way for
them to claim that there's institutional
white privilege and nationalized racism
happening whenever people disagree with
the media about whether a particular
incident is racist so there's an
ulterior motive that is going on here
from the media that I find really kind
of gross with regard to calling
President Trump racist I don't think
this is coming from an honest place for
a lot of people in the media who have
not been honest about labeling racism
wherever they see it they're fine with
the with the Obama administration
suggesting to black people that Mitt
Romney's gonna put them all back in
Chains that was fine but it's not fine
but but everything Trump says must be
taken exactly the same way this smacks
of media bias and the misuse of racism
as a term of art in order to slander
political opposition so in just a second
I'm going to show you the proof of this
I'm gonna show you that the the use of
the racism term is very often about an
ulterior motive in this particular case
it is about the situation with regard to
immigration so let's jump in there so
here is the here is the latest so all of
this was happening in the context of a
negotiation over daca over the deferred
action for childhood arrivals program
right all this is happening in that
context Trump is trying to make
and the deal is going to be that Trump
is suggesting that he wants border
security the building of a wall he
verify all of these goodies in return
for allowing the dreamers to stay
basically that's the deal and the
Democrats are trying to sink the deal
the Democrats don't want to deal the
Democrats showed up to this meeting with
Trump because they wanted to look like
they want a deal they don't actually
want a deal what they want is a clean
daca bill which they made pretty clear
during the meeting
and now they have an excuse to have a
clean daca bill because they're gonna go
to trump they're gonna say you're a
racist to any policy that you prescribe
is obviously motivated by racial animus
therefore no therefore no and that's
where they are going with this and Rand
Paul hits this pretty much on the head
he says listen you can't have an
immigration compromise if everybody is
busy calling Trump a racist well what I
regret is I do want to see an
immigration compromise and you can't
have an immigration compromise if
everybody's out there calling the
president a racist they're actually
destroying the setting and here's a
little bit of it but both sides now are
destroying the setting in which anything
meaningful can happen on there and I
think that is a hundred percent sure I
think it's being done on purpose as well
I think that Democrats who are jumping
on these telomer these comments were
made in private who leads them to the
media dick Durbin right it was dick
Durbin was the Democrat okay these were
not comments that were made in public
Trump did not say these things for
public consumption that doesn't
alleviate the responsibility that he
never should have said them but it does
show that the Democrats were leaking
this information specifically to sink
the daca talks that was one of the
things that they were doing and you see
this from Republicans like Jeff Flake so
Jeff Flake is beginning to irritate me I
like a lot of the things that Jeff Flake
has said in the past about the problems
with the Trump administration I think a
lot of those things are true but Jeff
Flake obviously has an ulterior motive
so he starts off by saying Trump said
over the weekend Democrats are
negotiating in bad faith the reason that
they're making a big deal out of the
bleep hole comments is because they want
to pull out of daca
and Jeff Flake says no no the Democrats
are negotiating in good faith they
really are they're there in good faith I
mean don't you see those who benefit
from this daca bill will not be able to
use chain migration to become citizens
we just don't do it for everybody
like the president wants to do if we
want a comprehensive bill I'm all-in but
we can't do a comprehensive bill which
take months and months to negotiate
before the the March 5th deadline and
one thing I do take big issue with the
president on as he is saying that the
Democrats aren't moving forward in good
faith I can tell you I've been
negotiating and working with the
Democrats on immigration for 17 years
and on this issue on daca or on the
DREAM Act for a number of years and the
Democrats are negotiating on some flakes
as the Democrats are negotiating good
faith but flake is not honest right
flake is not negotiating a good-faith
flake is supposed to give a speech on
the floor of the Senate today in which
he terms Trump's language on the media
Stalin desk I am not kidding about this
he's actually going to use the term
Stalin asked to describe Trump's
treatment of the media no one in the
media has been arrested no one the media
has been shut down nobody in the media
has been silenced nobody in the media is
really having a problem under the Trump
administration everybody's ratings are
up and access is better than it was
under the Obama administration Plus this
is a supremely leaky Trump
administration but here is flake
suggesting that Trump is just like
Stalin or something but we're supposed
to believe that he has no ulterior
motive and going after Trump well he
borrowed that phrase it was popularized
by Joseph Stalin used by Mao as well
enemy of the people it should be noted
that Nikita Khrushchev who followed
stolen for bad its use saying that that
that was too loaded that a maligned a
whole group or class of people and it
shouldn't be done I don't think that we
should be using a phrase that's been
rejected as too loaded I didn't like the
phrase when Trump used it either but to
suggest that Trump is somehow in line
with Mao and Stalin is just insane these
people responsible for tens of millions
of deaths
it's just crazy but what his flakes
ulterior motive here spikes ulterior
motive he's asked whether he wants to
run for president in 2020 you say you
should oppose him when you think he's
wrong do you think that there is a moral
obligation or duty for someone else in
your party to challenge him for the
nomination in 2020 to put
way but I think he will have a challenge
from you he'll certainly have a
challenge as if somebody isn't
independent but I think you'll likely
have a challenge in the Republican Party
as well I'm not the only one not the
only Republican who was saying you know
I'm not sure this is this is my party
okay so he's basically saying maybe I'll
run okay so that's the ulterior motive
right there so this is why I say when
people start throwing around the racism
charge you have to determine whether
they're doing it because this is just
their honest assessment of the situation
or whether there is another goal that is
being pursued here dick Durbin another
example okay dick Durbin again is the
guy who leaked the bleep hole comments
in the first place again this is not to
absolve Trump of responsibility for
saying something intensely stupid in
front of Democrats and maybe quasi
racist depending on your interpretation
but when dick durbin suggests that that
he is somehow a brokering in good faith
that's absurd I mean he actually said
over the weekend that the term chain
migration is offensive to people whose
ancestors came over and chained okay the
term chain migration just to briefly
explain the term chain migration means
that I come and then like a chain I pull
in all of my relatives to come into the
United States it has nothing to do with
physical shackles used upon slaves
that's absurd but here is dick Durbin a
guy who once compared American soldiers
to pull pot and the Nazis on the floor
of the Senate suggesting that Trump
shouldn't use terms like chain migration
because offensive to black people to the
issue of quote chain migration I said to
the president do you realize how painful
that term is to so many people come on
Americans believe that they migrated to
America in Chains and when you speak
about chain migration it hurts them
personally
he said oh that's a good line I mean
come on come on
dick durbin wants to sink these talks
that's the whole purpose of sending him
Trump should have known that Trump
should been weary when he was in the
room with him it's dumb of Trump but
again I think that when you're in
political situations it is imperative
that you be a little more cynical than
just suggesting that everybody is
operating in the best of faith and that
everyone was so deeply offended that
Trump said something okay let's be real
about this they all know who Trump is
everybody knows who Trump is at this
point and the idea that everyone is
sitting around being deeply offended at
Trump not using that offense is sort of
a faux outrage in order to sink daca
Talks is silly obviously one thing has
very much to do with another here and
again and none of this is to deny that
Trump has done or said racist things in
the past I don't think that that's that
I don't think that's deniable frankly
but I think the idea that Trump is
overall a racist yeah as I get older I'm
more and more hesitant anyone I was
younger it's easier to just label people
as a whole somebody's a hero somebody's
a villain that's a good person that's a
bad person the reality is that as you
get older you tend to try and determine
on one by one basis calling balls and
strikes you know there's a person who's
trustworthy and somebody you trust there
might be a person and that dictates your
action you know your action toward them
is dictated by your view of their
character this person doesn't have
character but I think that that that can
only be used as a backdrop it can't be
used as the dispositive statement about
every one of their actions you may
believe in other words that Trump is a
racist but it's still incumbent on you
to analyze every one of his actions and
determine whether that is a racist
action or statement and not just jump to
the conclusion based on your perception
of his worldview that you don't have
full evidence for is I think where I
would go with that and I think it's true
in in everyday life as well okay so in
just the second out and talk about the
me2 movement and where it is going
wildly wrong because it has now plus
will get to Hawaii but first we're going
to have to break on on on Facebook and
YouTube so if you want to watch the rest
of the show
you need to head over right now to daily
wire.com for $9.99 a month you get a
subscription to daily wire calm that
means that you get the rest of my show
live you get to be part of my mailbag it
means that you get to be part of an rou
clayvin still alive you get to be part
of his mailbag part of Michael Moses
show live lots of goodies for you when
you subscribe plus we're gonna have
discounts at the Shapiro store and all
the rest also time to get those wheels
turning and the keyboards tell me
because tomorrow
January 16th 5:00 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m.
Pacific we're doing our fifth episode of
the conversation featuring Andrew Clavin
moderated by Alicia Krause subscribe
today be part of the conversation to ask
drew live questions he will answer for
everyone to hear
Drew's conversation will stream live on
the daily wire Facebook page and the
daily wire YouTube channel will be free
for everyone to watch but only
subscribers can ask the questions to ask
questions as a subscriber log into our
website over daily wire.com head over to
the conversation page to watch the live
stream after that just start typing into
the daily wired chat box andrew will
answer questions as they come in for an
entire hour again subscribe to get your
questions answered by andrew Clavin on
Tuesday January 16th at 5 p.m. Eastern 2
p.m. Pacific and join the conversation
or later make sure that you check us out
at soundcloud itunes google play
stitcher for the annual subscription by
the way it's 99 bucks you get all of
those aforementioned glori's Plus this
the leftist year's hot or cold tumbler
which is filled to overflowing every day
so check it out over at daily wire.com
we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so it looks like the me2 movement is now
evolving and that it is gone wildly
wrong as evidence for this there is a
piece in a magazine called babe I'd
never heard of it before and it was
written by a woman in Katy way and Katy
way details anonymous allegations by a
photographer who had an awkward and
terrible intimate evening with comedian
Aziz Ansari I won't explain those
allegations in just a second and show
you in detail why the me2 movement is
off the rails first I think it is
necessary to quote a woman because I
don't want a man's playing this to you
first of all I think that we need to
stop with the woman's planning of men's
motives right the woman's planning of
men's motives this idea that women can
read men's minds and they know that
we're all pigs and all evil and all
nasty and all terrible and all brutish
and all willing to overcome their
consent and that they're always in
danger of rape don't woman explained to
me my own mind okay I'm not kind of
man's plan to you your mind but you
don't get to a woman's plane to me my
mind
either okay we can have general views of
how people should use their rationality
and I think that's perfectly fine but to
attribute motivations to men generally
is no better than men attributing
motivations to women generally I think
in any case here's condi rice saying we
are in danger of turning this me to
movement into into a snowflake moment
for a lot of women I think that the
movement to expose these these
circumstances is a good thing let's
clear the air about it I do think we
have to be a little bit careful let's
not turn women into snowflakes let's not
infantilize women and what I really
don't want to happen is that I wanted to
get to a place that men start to think
well maybe it's just better not to have
women around well and unfortunately
that's the way that it is going because
if every activity by a man can be
perceived as sexual assault or sexual
harassment men will stop hiring women
they will they will stop working with
women this actually happened in the
aftermath of the American with
Disabilities Act the idea was that if
you are a workplace you now have to
install if you have a disabled employee
you have to install ramps everywhere and
all the rest of it you can't just have
an elevator or somebody help you up the
stairs if she have to have ramps and so
the employment for Americans with
disabilities actually declined or
actually went down so that's that's a
serious you know that's a serious
consequence when she says that that
Consensus being dumbed down that agency
is being dumbed down this is a 100% true
now men are not only supposed to
determine whether a woman wants to do
something they're supposed to decide for
the woman whether she wants to do
something the case in point is this Aziz
Ansari case so let me start with this I
think Aziz Ansari is a jerk yeah as he's
unsound 'he's like a douchebag and Aziz
Ansari he's one of these guys where's
the timings up button and then sounds
like he treats women in a kind of trashy
fashion but this story is not a story of
sexual assault it's a bad penthouse
letter that's all it is okay and this
was printed and it got all sorts of play
and Aziz Ansari was essentially accused
of sexual assault allegations it's
really insane okay so Ansari is a
nincompoop as matt walsh points out but
this woman who calls herself grace she
met ansari at the emmy awards in 2017
she approaches him he blows her off but
she ends up leaving with Ansari's number
in her phone anyway and then they go on
a date and then azhari
Ansari only offers her white wine even
though she prefers red okay like
presumably she could have said something
about it but then he wants to get her
back to her his place okay now at this
point if you are a person with any
semblance of rationality you're thinking
the guy basically wants to rush through
dinner to get me back to his apartment
what do you think is going to happen at
his apartment is he desperate to go home
and play Parcheesi does the guy house
these on sorry I really want this woman
to go back home with him and they're
just gonna play twister like with their
clothes on like that's that's really his
intent going back of course not the
woman knows going back the probably some
sexual interplay is going to happen
there so the two start going at it as
Matt Walsh points out as soon as they
arrive in their apartment they take
their clothes off they perform various
acts of sex here's the actual story
right so she says he resumed kissing her
okay so first of all they get undressed
Ansari says that he wants to grab a
prophylactic and women objecting whoa
let's relax for a second let's chill and
then she continues she says he then
resumed kissing her briefly performed
certain sex acts upon her and asked her
to do the same thing to him which she
did but not for a long quote it was
really quick everything was pretty much
touched and done within 10 minutes of
hooking up except for actual sex and no
point in here did she ever say no I'm
uncomfortable with this let's stop and
when she did guess what he stopped she
accused Ansari of pulling her hand
toward his genitals several times but
she never got up to leave and every time
she said no or evidence that she didn't
want to do something he stopped so he
was persistent but he
was not physically moving her he was not
physically forcing her when she when she
said no he didn't stop her when she
pulled the weight and stopped her and
but here's what she says throughout the
course of her short time in the
apartment she said she'd verbal and
nonverbal cues to indicate how
uncomfortable and distress she was well
he could have quoted it did she ever say
I don't want to do this in fact one time
she does say I don't want to do this and
that's how full-on penetrative sex she
says I don't want to do this and guess
what they don't right the woman says I
know I was physically giving off cues I
wasn't interested okay this idea that
you know you were physically giving off
use unless you were actively pushing him
away the idea that you were physically
giving off cues that you're not
interested men aren't good with these
cues okay men are not good with these
physical cues the you may have thought
that you are sitting there saying no I'm
not interested but if you are not at
like really to expect him to read your
version on verbal cues is insane it's a
people are bad at reading each other's
cues generally but this is particularly
true when hormones are running high and
you're in a room naked with each other
but it turns out that's a pretty big
nonverbal cue to a dude that you might
want to have sex but if you're in a room
naked with a guy making out with him and
performing certain sex acts with one
another we could call that a nonverbal
cue that you might be into things right
you know I know this because I'm married
and when my wife doesn't want to have
sex with me she's not in a room naked
with me it turns out amazing how this
works okay and then the cues as I say
the cues weren't best ambiguous but she
told Ansari she didn't want to have sex
because she didn't want to feel force he
said okay and then they sat on the couch
and he asked her for another sex act and
here's what it says Ansari instructed
her to turn around he sat back and
pointed his genitals and motion for me
to perform the sex act and I did I think
I just felt really pressured yeah I was
literally the most unexpected thing I
thought would happen at that moment
because I told him I was uncomfortable
wasn't the most unexpected thing you
thought was gonna happen at that moment
like more expecting like a dragon
popping through the window and blow in
flame at you was the most unexpected
thing that you were having you're in the
middle of a of a sexual evening and he
asked you to perform a sex act that you
had already performed earlier in the
evening and then he did it was the most
unexpected thing like really was it
shocking to you you never could have
imagined it it was like Chris Farley
coming back to life and busting through
the apartment door like that woulda been
unexpected I feel like I feel like a lot
I feel like a pizza arriving at that
moment might have been a more unexpected
I feel like I feel like the new episode
of Game of Thrones dropping might have
been more like there are a few things in
life that might have been a little more
unexpected then you in the middle of
having a bunch of sex acts with a guy
him asking you to perform something than
you doing it also which part of the
nonverbal cue was it when you started
actually performing the sex act again
the woman can feel however she wants I'm
sure she felt used I'm sure she felt
awkward because she shouldn't have been
there in the first place
okay she can make that choice but then
she doesn't get to say the next day by
the way he should have figured out that
I felt awkward he asked you to do
something and you did it I don't know
how he's supposed to read your mind
again it doesn't make ends as he's in
sorry any less of a jerk it doesn't mean
he's not gross it doesn't mean that you
ought to feel like you that you have no
right to feel how you want to feel you
can feel however you want to feel but
what we are arguing about now is whether
there was an objective measure by which
Aziz Ansari he disobeyed your consent
but there was some objective measure by
which we could lock Aziz Ansari up or
ruin his career over this and the answer
I'm finding is no okay this is a bad
pent house diary entry nothing in the
piece suggests sound sorry to command to
the woman she acquiesced to performing
oral sex not once but twice no physical
force was alleged at any time okay and
then she says well you know I texted him
afterward should I texted him afterward
she says that in she did she texted him
he texted her and said thanks but it was
nice to meet you last night which by the
way shows there is something wildly
wrong with our sexual culture right you
literally met and then you had this
evening and then you text it was nice to
meet you we've totally reversed the
polarity and the in the order of when
you're supposed to have sex in American
society the way I grew up was you get to
know a woman you tell you get to love a
woman you marry a woman you commit to a
woman and then you have sex with the
woman and we've completely reversed all
of those things right now it will have
sex and maybe it was fun maybe it wasn't
and I'll text you the next day maybe and
then you're surprised the men aren't
picking up the cues men are stupid
particularly with regard to sex men are
morons okay this is I'm fully unaware as
to when culture I don't understand one
culture decided that men were brilliant
with regards to their penises like this
this has never been true in the history
of humanity like going all the way back
to Adam and Eve my men are not smart
with regard
to this stuff but now men are supposed
to be Carnac the magnificent and they're
supposed to be able to mind-read I mean
really this is the end of me - if you
want a meaty movement that means
something you actually have to restrict
bad activity to activity that has some
sort of standard and there are people
who are tweeting out well you know there
various levels of consent right I
actually agree that there are various
levels of consent which is why committed
relationships are useful and why you
shouldn't have sex with men you don't
know because when you know people then
you are more likely to take into account
the various levels of consent okay there
are times when women are reluctant to
have sex and they're more reluctant and
what a man will do if he loves the woman
and they have a committed relationship
will say okay she's more reluctant
she'll do it if I push her a little bit
and it won't be like I'm raping her
but she's more reluctant and maybe I'll
just let it go this time right but the
guy is that like in this situation she's
there for sex he's there for sex they
just met he brought her back to his
apartment you think that Aziz Ansari
really cares for this girl obviously not
and then she's using his texts against
her right so she texts that I think the
actual text said something like I'm
trying to find the actual time I hear it
she said she had to so she texted a
friend she had to say no a lot he wanted
sex okay and then she said no a lot and
then he didn't have sex with it also had
to say no a lot used to be the standard
definition of male-female relationships
guess what women say no a lot to men and
good men respect to know hey later she
texts it on sorry last night might have
been fun for you but it wasn't for me
you ignored clear nonverbal cues again
nonverbal cues maybe you didn't ignore
them maybe he's just being persistent
because sometimes nonverbal cues are
ambiguous like again being naked and
performing sex acts with one another and
she says you kept going with advances I
want to make sure you're aware so maybe
the next girl doesn't have to cry on the
ride home Ansari replied I'm so sad to
hear this clearly I misread things in
the moment I'm truly sorry
okay that's and then they're reading
that as evidence that he's admitting
that he raped her or something okay
that's him being mildly polite what are
you gonna say to this crazy lady okay
are you really gonna say to this woman
you know what you're wrong I didn't read
those verbal that those nonverbal cues
and then she blows it up he's hoping if
I just say something nice then she goes
away that's what I was he's on sorry is
open okay all of this is stupid and it's
why the me2 movement is doing itself a
massive disservice right the Miche
movement is doing itself a massive
disservice
of course the woman feels used because
she was used but she made the decision
to be there and be used and give off a
lot of nonverbal cues that suggest that
she wanted to be used and the fact she
felt bad about it the next day or during
the act you know it's the easiest way to
not feel bad about things don't do them
okay that's the easiest way to not feel
bad about things and don't expect the
guy to care for you or be nice to you or
be cordial to you or make up your mind
for you by the way if she had said
listen I don't think you're going to
have sex right now and she could come
out the next day instead he deprived me
of my agency I really did want to have
sex then and he was making up my mind
for me you can't have it both ways on
this either you are responsible for your
own consent or you are not responsible
for your own consent particularly in
situations where you don't love the
person you're having sex with and it's
not in the confines of anything remotely
resembling a committed relationship okay
so now I want to move on to the
situation Hawaii from one disaster area
to another so over the weekend there was
a false alarm that went out in Hawaii
that suggested that there was a nuclear
attack imminent in Hawaii and people
went nuts Oh people were actually taking
their kids and putting them in storm
drains and then taping it which I don't
know like why you would do this so you
want this for the family album later I'm
always bewildered it's in the middle of
an emergency people are grabbing their
phones to take the emergency as opposed
to you know getting to a safe place in
any case here is here's a little bit of
this tape okay so they're putting the
kid in the in the storm drain which is
just great and then Jim Carrey of course
blamed Trump which makes perfect sense
because somehow Trump's fault but some
idiot in Hawaii on the state level hit
the button that said that there is a
nuclear attack imminent so he said I
woke up this morning in Hawaii with 10
minutes to live it was a false alarm but
a real psychic warning if we allow this
one man Gomorrah and his corrupt
Republican Congress to continue
alienating the world they're all headed
for suffering beyond all imagination
then Jim Carrey tweeted out like a
picture of a mushroom cloud what now
what does Trump have to do with any of
this like this is a state that is run by
Democrats I'm confused in fact the state
is so incompetent of this that the
worker was not even fired the worker was
reassigned I'm not joking the worker is
still working can they just move him to
a different area it's so hard to find
government employees that when you send
out an alert to your entire state that
everyone's about to be nuked in 10
minutes
you retain your
hobb hey the government may be too big
and too bad and everything that it does
so no this is not Trump's fault okay I
know you wanna blend from for everything
but no this one is actually not Trump's
fault and that's really really really
really really stupid okay so time for
some things I like and then some things
that I hate and we will do a Federalist
paper so the things I like so today is
of course Martin Luther King Day his
birthday is indeed more important than
mine is one of the things that's totally
insane is the way people are covering
Martin Luther King Day so instead of
just looking at the stuff that people
actually pay tribute to they decide to
look at his entire life there are lots
of this is what I was saying about great
men or important people or heroes or
villains everybody has stuff that they
that they've done that is not why we pay
tribute to them so Winston Churchill had
some pretty nasty racial things to say
during the course of his life the reason
we pay tribute to Winston Churchill is
because of his strength in the face of
the Nazis and in the face of the
Communists Martin Luther King we paid
tribute to his strength in the face of
racial discrimination not we don't care
that much about his economic policy CNN
is trying to make it that we care about
his economic policy that's just silly
okay this is the same thing the left
tries to do with George Washington where
George Washington is honored cuz he's
the father of the country not because he
held slaves but they say well it's
really his slave owners it's his status
as a slave owner that matters no no okay
in any case if you want you know kind of
the the basic take I'm Martin Luther
King jr. and why it's good and well you
should read your kid today there's a
great book called I am Martin Luther
King jr. it's by Brad Meltzer it's
illustrated by Christopher le le appleís
I think I've I believe I've recommended
at least one of these books in the
series before there there's there's one
about Jackie Robinson that's quite good
there's one about Albert Einstein that's
very good
I think I recommended I'm George
Washington which is also a favorite of
my daughters and the whole point of this
book is it really does tell the basic
story of Martin Luther King jr. you know
sounds assassination it does tell the
entire kind of basic story of why he's
an important figure in American history
my daughter loves this book it's really
kind of beautifully written and it's
well as Ron and it's fun to read and so
check that out that's it that's a good
way to educate your kid about Martin
Luther King jr. and Martin Luther King
jr. Day today okay other things that I
like so I have to show you the final
play of the Vikings Saints game if you
didn't see this and you're not a
football fan this will make you into a
football fan so the Saints we're leading
2423 and you're about to watch the worst
tackle in the history of the NFL right
here and it leads to the Vikings winning
the game on a miracle play
[Applause]
okay so that's an insane way that guy
that I missed tackle is just a career
ender I mean the if you can't see it the
fellow from the Saints I don't know the
defensive backs name that is inexcusable
I mean it just basic missed missed
tackle holy moly
how do you miss that tackle that's
insane and then they run into each other
which is it turns into a Benny Hill
sequence but great play and now we get
the fantastic spectacle watching two of
the worst quarterbacks in the league go
after each other next week it's Nick
Foles versus Case Keenum so that will be
awesome in the in the NFC Championship
game okay time for a quick thing that I
hate and then we'll do a federalist
paper okay the quick thing that I hate
we will see you know we'll talk about
Trump and paying a hundred thirty
thousand dollars allegedly to a porn
star tomorrow I really don't have much
to say on that other than like are we
shocked are we surprised it's not
something I hate because it's something
that I sort of figured I mean Donald
Trump is not speaking of people who are
not particularly smart about where they
put their win wing this is the president
definitely falls into that list okay
other things that I hate Chelsea Manning
now wants to run for US Senate so I
think this is just great we've got Joe
Arpaio running for the Senate on the
right we've got Chelsea Manning running
for the Senate on the left and this is
the campaign ad for for Chelsea Manning
in the US Senate Chelsea Manning of
course is a traitor is an actual traitor
who's whose time in prison for revealing
classified documents that put American
lives in danger and then got out because
Chelsea Manning is transgender and
obviously all transgender people are
heroes right just like all gay people
are heroes and all minorities are heroes
Chelsea Manning deserved to be released
from prison not because Chelsea Manning
wasn't guilty of traitor of treason but
because Chelsea Manning thinks that
Chelsea Manning is a woman and it's very
important to the press that we all agree
so here is Chelsea Manning's campaign ad
we live in trying time
times of fear of suppression didn't
anima Skutt this add hate you don't need
more or better readers we need someone
willing to fight we need to stop asking
them to give us our rights they won't
support us
they won't compromise we need to stop
expecting that our systems will somehow
fix themselves we need to actually take
the reins of power from them
we need to challenge them at every level
holding a rose what is this we don't
need them anymore we can do better
what is dam night we got this okay we
got this is his Chelsea Manning's
hashtag and Chelsea Manning uses emoji
like the actual ad has on it emojis and
hashtags Chelsea Manning has some
serious problems okay Chelsea Manning
and I'm not even talking about the
transgenderism right now I'm talking
about the serious problems Chelsea
Manning has with being a traitor and
then thinking that that he is going to
run for US Senate
hashtag we got this rainbow flag emoji
sunglasses if that gets in the United
States Senate if Chelsea Manning is in
the United Stated that person is in the
United States Senate I mean just
whatever I guess it wouldn't let's be
frank it wouldn't decline the quality of
the Senate that much I'm probably I mean
okay time for a quick Federalist Papers
so every week we do a Federalist paper
here's a quick summary of Federalist 11
Federalist 11 is by Alexander Hamilton
this one has to do with trade
negotiation Hamilton making the case for
the Constitution of the United States
and the federal government he says other
countries want to divide us on trade in
order to make us less powerful that's
basically why we should have one country
so that we can negotiate with other
countries on an equal level
he also says we need to build a powerful
Navy so that we can have a chance of
being a powerful nation and then he
makes a fantastic point a really
interesting one I actually want to read
it to you so only a couple sentences
this is from Hamilton talking about what
the US has role in the world can be in
overthrowing European visions of
ethnocentrism it's really fascinating he
says you're and remember Alexander
Hamilton grew up outside the United
States as a bastard child said Europe
buy her arms and buy her negotiations by
force and by fraud has in different
degrees extended her dominion over them
all Africa Asia and America have felt
successively heard a minute her
domination the superiority she has long
maintained has tempted her to plume
herself as mistress of the world and to
consider the rest of mankind is created
for her benefit men admired his profound
philosophers having direct terms
attributed to her inhabitants of
physical superiority have gravely
asserted that all animals and what them
the human species degenerate in America
thought that even dogs cease to bark
after having breathed a while in our
atmosphere
facts of too long supported these
arrogant pretensions of the Europeans it
belongs to us to vindicate the honor of
the human race and to teach that
assuming brother moderation and to teach
that assuming brother moderation Union
will enable us to do so this Union will
add another to the victim of his triumph
when Americans sustained to be the
instruments of European greatness so
what he's saying now
is you want to prove that America is not
filled with a lesser stock then become a
successful country he's basically saying
that Europe has essentially seen itself
as the leader because it has victimized
other countries let's become a non
victim country and then we'll
demonstrate to everyone that Americans
are not a lesser stock and it's
interesting you can apply that same
logic everywhere across the world the
best revenge against racism is dominance
the best revenge against ethnocentrism
is success the best revenge against the
stupidity of people saying that you
can't be a good immigrant from Haiti is
the Haitian success rate right that
that's that's the best revenge and
Alexander Hamilton Hamilton talks about
explicitly in Federalist 11 which is
quite fascinating and I think
appropriate for Martin Luther King Day
okay so we'll be back here tomorrow with
all the latest i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex Zingaro
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess well para the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2017